[Music]
you
ever wondered what he was thinking or
her or maybe you've always wanted to
express your feelings without saying a
word what if you could read someone's
mind and they could read yours would
there be no secrets left would mind
control become possible - and how could
you keep your privacy if everyone knew
what was on your mind this is what if
and here's what would happen if brain to
brain communication was possible let's
be honest the way we communicate is
pretty slow it takes time from the
moment the thought comes to your mind to
the moment you say it to someone even
longer with your two finger typing our
brain is much faster than that on
average you have 50,000 thoughts a day
that's 35 thoughts per minute you can't
type all of them nor can you put them
into words imagine how fast we could
exchange information if we could just
transmit our thoughts directly to
another brain once we started
communicating through thought we turn
into a giant mind-melding Network
humanity would become much more
innovative since the more people shared
their ideas the more other people would
be able to improve upon them this would
boost technology to a level we can't yet
imagine
sharing our knowledge through thoughts
would also make us more coordinated this
would not only benefit all military
structures but also emergency services
you'd be able to think 9-1-1 instead of
calling them very handy if your phone's
dead
we'd be learning much faster and easier
instead of verbally explaining a
difficult concept your teacher could
give you a better representation of it
through thought and don't forget things
with artificial intelligence if your car
had a mind of its own you'd be able to
control it with your mind same goes for
your phone computer robot pet anything
that might have an AI while controlling
things sounds awesome what if this led
to controlling people's minds it might
sound interesting but it wouldn't seem
that great if you were the one being
controlled
luckily the way it would work would be
that just like we can choose what to say
we'd be able to choose what thoughts to
share with others no one would read your
thoughts unless you let them that's a
relief isn't it this new era of
mind-reading would be pretty silent
without the need to push air through our
lungs and into our voice box we might
eventually forget language and the sound
of it but at least you'd never struggle
to tell your crush exactly how you felt
about them you'd literally show them
your feelings we don't know much about
our bundle of neurons we don't fully
understand why we sleep or how our
consciousness works but we do know how
to read our brain yep you heard it right
our brain fires neurons that receive
transmit and process information through
electrical and chemical signals and we
can read those signals with the help of
this method electroencephalography or
EEG what's more we can now transmit
information from one brain to another we
have a meth
for that transcranial magnetic
stimulation or TMS this stimulation
sends electrical current to the
receivers brain activating a small area
of it the same one that was active in
the sender's brain that might not
exactly be the telepathy from science
fiction but that's what talking through
thought would look like in real life and
we don't always talk we use devices to
communicate with each other eventually
we just switched to faster technologies
the ones that would let you send your
thoughts the way you send your emails do
you think you'll still be around to use
EEG zatt TMS is instead of your mobile
phone
[Music]
[Applause]